let's say you're a lion here you are in
your home in Africa going on a hunt you
are magnificently equipped for your life
as a predator you've got long canine
teeth huge claws a powerful stride
amazing agility plus the sense you're
using here an acute sense of hearing as
a lion you're a social animal you hunt
with your pride about the only flaw in
your hunting is stamina you have great
acceleration but you can't hunt your
prey for long distances that's why
you're doing what you're doing here
listening stalking trying to get close
the grasslands and brush around you give
you excellent cover however most of the
time your prey picks up your scent and
the hunt fails you move on and sometimes
the pride gets
pater bringing down a wildebeest
here's where collaboration and
competition is revealed once the
wildebeest is stricken you and the
entire pie pile on every lion helps in
the kill but you compete with every lion
for a share of the meat for a lion cub
this is a crucial test if the cub can't
feed itself
he'll star it must get its share right
here is when the abdomen of the
wildebeest is torn open the choicest
portions are now available and
competition is at its most fierce
beginning yes good and you fight for
your fair share by the end of the meal
you're injured along with most of the
pride you don't really notice you know a
full stomach does then you back off
letting the younger Cubs get access to
the carcass now you and the rest of the
pride groom one another
[Music]
whatever bonds were bruised over the
feed are fixed up here as you mel lick
and make up